المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان
ثمانيه مواطنين فلسطينيين اصيبوا بجروح
خطيره بنيران قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي توغلت وسط البلد القديمه بنابلس صباح
اليوم وقد اعلنت بلديه نابلس تاجيل بدء
الدراسه في كافه مدارس المدينه بسبب هذا
التوغل العسكري الاسرائيلي بينما اعلن
المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال ان قوات
المشتركه من الجيش وجهاز الامن العام
الشباك والوحدات الخاصه من الشرطه وحرس
الحدود قد بدات عمليه عسكريه في البلده
القديمه في نابلس صباح اليوم
معنا من رام الله مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البوديري جيفارا ما الذي توفر من معلومات
حول هذا التوغل وما خلفياته
حتى الان قوات الاحتلال المعززه تحاصر
معظم انحاء البلده القديمه في مدينه نابلس
او اطلاق النار ايضا يسمع في كل انحاء
مدينه نابلس سواء من قبل قوات الاحتلال
التي تطلق النار على الشبان فلسطينيين
يرشقون الحجاره او بسبب وهو بالاهم بالطبع
والاوسع الاشتباكات المسلحه الدائره بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وجنود الاحتلال بالطبع
ايضا وزاره التربيه والتعليم في نابلس
اعلنت تاخير الدوام بسبب خطوره الوضع حسب
وصفها وايضا الدوائر الرسميه والحكوميه
والخاصه بالطبع كانت قواتها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بدايه وكما راينا خلال الاشهر
الماضيه قد توغلت الى داخل احد الاحياء
والازقه تحديدا حاره في البلده القديمه
دخلت بدايه واحده من المستعربين هم جنودا
من وحده خاصه من النخبه يرتدون زين
فلسطينيا بداوا بمحاصره منزل في داخل
الحاره ومن ثم عند كشف امرهم بدات تعزيزات
كبيره من قوات الاحتلال تدخل تباعا سواء
الى داخل المدينه او محاصره المدينه من
الخارج وايضا داخل ازقه البلده القديمه
وحاره الياسمينه ومنطقه الفاطميه بطبعا من
بين الاصابات وفق الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
على الاقل هناك اصابه واحده خطيره جدا
اصابه بالظهر من قبل الرصاص بسبب الرصاص
الذي اطلقه جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هناك
عدد من الاصابات في صفوف الاطفال وطلبت
المدارس بسبب قنابل الغاز التي يطلقها
جنود الاحتلال في هذه الاثناء ومنذ حوالي
نصف ساعه بشكل عشوائي وضعت قنابل الغاز
دخلت في احدى الساحات لمدرسه قريبه من
البلده القديمه اذا الامور تتطور شيئا
وعندما يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان
رسمي انه يقوم الان بعمل عسكري في داخل
مدينه نابلس هذا معناه انه نتحدث عن عمليه
كبيره خلفيات هذه العمليه بالطبع لا تختلف
عن العمليات السابقه مزاعم الاحتلال
كالعاده الوصول الى المقاومين ومن تصفهم
بالمطلوبين لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ولكن هذه العمليه تاتي بعد اقل من اربع من
48 ساعه على استشهاد الاسير الشيخ خضر
عدنان وحاله التفاعل الشعبي وبعض
المراقبين يرون ان هذه العمليه هي ايضا
ضمن التنافس الداخلي الاسرائيلي سواء بسبب
الضغوطات على نتنياهو في الوضع الداخلي او
بسبب ما يطالب به مثلا وزير الامن الداخلي
الاسرائيلي لتمار بن جفير بانه لن يكون في
داخل الائتلاف الحكومي ان لم يقم نتنياهو
بما هو اكثر من ذلك بالطبع وفق مصادر
فلسطينيه لا نؤكدها وصلنا انه على الاقل
قوات الاحتلال في المنزل الذي تحاصره يوجد
ما يقارب من ثمانيه مطل ثمانيه شبان
فلسطينيين ولكن كما ذكرنا هي عن مصادر
فلسطينيه وتحديدا الاذاعه الرسميه
الفلسطينيه هي ايضا من ذكرت هذا النبا
ولكن لا احد يعرف ما الذي يحدث ايضا الان
بدات
المكبرات الصوت في المساجد المدينه تطلب
من الاهالي ومن المقاومين بمحاوله الوصول
الى داخل الماده القديمه فك الحصار عنها
وتحديدا ايضا على المنزل الذي قامت قوات
الاحتلال بتفجير مدخله الدخول هل تمكنت
قوات الاحتلال من الدخول الى هذا المنزل
نحن لا زلنا لا نعلم لان عاده في هكذا
اثناء تكون كل التجديدات الامنيه حتى
الطواقم الطبيه لم تدخل حتى اللحظه الى
داخل
البلده القديمه ولا ولا اي طبيب او مسعف
يستطيع الوصول سواء الى المكان الذي يحاصر
فيه المنزل او الى داخل البلده القديمه
لان الحديث عن اصابات موجوده في الازقه
وكما ذكرنا فقط الحديث الان عن اصابه
واحده خطيره واصابه ثانيه
ويبدو ان الطواقم الطبيه وصلت الى
الاصابه فصلنا مباشره
توفق
للتوغل عربات عسكريه اسرائيليه لمدينه
نابلس كما ذكرنا قبل قليل في الخبر
والسؤال هنا جيفارا عن هل هناك معلومات عن
الحاله الصحيه لهؤلاء الثمانيه
الفلسطينيين الذين اصيبوا خلال هذه
العمليه
الان ما وصلنا من الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
انه هناك اصابه واحده نقلت الى المستشفى
واصابه متواجده في داخل احد المنازل
المحاصره
في داخل البلده القديمه اذا وفق الهلال
الاحمر اصابه واحده نقلت الى المستشفى
واخرى متواجده داخل منزل يصعب هناك صعوبه
في الوصول اليه ومدرسه فيها اطفال وكما
ذكرنا فان قوات الاحتلال اطلقت قنابل
الغاز بشكل عشوائي سواء في الازقه او في
داخل احدى المدارس
القريبه اذا نتحدث حتى الان عن ثماني
اصابات من بين الاصابتان من بين الاصابات
هناك فلسطينيين اصيب بالرصاص الحي احدى
الاصابات هي اصابه خطيره
وصفت حسب المصادر الطبيه رغم عدم تمكن
الطواقم الطبيه الفلسطينيه من الدخول
والوصول الى داخل ازقه البلده القديمه
وتحديدا الى حاره الياسمين فقط هنا لنوضح
البلده القديمه هي من اكثر المناطق
الاثريه القديمه جدا في فلسطين وبالتالي
المنازل هي متراصه قريبه جدا من بعضها
وبالتالي الاضرار لا تصيب منزل بعينه
عندما نرى تفجير من بعيد ونرى السنه دخان
تتصاعد من داخل البلده القديمه هذا لا
يعني ان فقط منزل واحد هو الذي تضرر او
اصابات موجوده
عفوا في داخل هذا المنزل ولكن بالتاكيد
سيكون هناك
ما كنا نراه في الفترات الماضيه والسنوات
الماضيه يكون هناك اصابات في المنطقه
المحيطه ولكن حتى اللحظه الجيش الاسرائيلي
لم يؤكد ما الفرق ما الجدوى او ما هي
اهداف هذه العمليه نعم تبقين معنا جيفارا